[Music]  in los angeles somebody or a team has  been murdering girls lots of them  everybody was really on edge and worried  they could be next  kenneth bianchi is a suspect in several  of the los angeles hillside strangler  murders scary things were happening  inside of me he was claiming a split  personality  he keeps saying i killed those girls i  did tied him up killed one killed the  other if he had multiple personalities  why didn't i ever see one  he hatched this plan i was going to  replicate a murder and i did it to make  it look like he was innocent and if  bianchi was a liar he's trying to save  himself  there was never any doubt in my mind  that there was at least two suspects i  wonder where the other guy is  how do we know that it's not a lie well  you don't you're just gonna have to take  my word for it  [Music]  you